in this video I'm gonna talk about
effects you can do in jQuery we just
have a few elements on the page I have
an image and h1 tag and then a paragraph
that you can see on the page there and
I'm gonna first talk about the hide
event so we'll just type in the jQuery
selector and then we're just gonna do a
that hide and that's it so if I run this
code with just the image dot hide it's
gonna hide the image image just
disappears you can see now it's like
that image isn't even in the code there
and if you need help
adding jQuery to your website you can
check out my first video on jQuery where
I show you how to add jQuery after you
hide an element you can show the element
so I just have to select it again and
then just do dot show and now you're
barely gonna be able to tell anything
cuz it's gonna hide it and then show it
right away so hide and show just hides
and show instantly but you can use
animation in a couple of ways so you can
pass in arguments to hide in show so it
won't do it instantly I can pass in slow
to make it a slow effect or fast to make
it a fast effect you can also use normal
so let's see what that looks like see it
disappeared slowly and then it came back
quickly so instead of putting words slow
and fast you can also put in the number
of milliseconds so I'm gonna put 500
milliseconds to hide it that's a half a
second and then 1500 milliseconds to
show at 1.5 seconds so let's see what
that looks like okay so you can really
do any speed you want by just passing in
a number like that and let's just see
what that looks like if I do on the h1
tag so here I'm gonna change this to h1
and let's try that so you can see it
looks actually kind of different h1 this
is a show and hide effect use a
combination of slide and fade effects
with the slide effect it's actually is
changing the height really quickly so
it's lowering the height unto 0 and with
an image when you lower the height that
also automatically change
changes the width but with an h1 when
you change the height that does not
automatically change the width so that's
why the h1 looked like it was I'm just
coming straight down and up and then the
image looked like it was going into a
little corner so showing hide used slide
and fade at the same time but you can
also use one or the other since so if
height or show I'm going to use slide up
or I can use slide down so now it's not
going to change the opacity at all it's
just gonna slide it up and down and you
can still use this slow normal or fast
or you can use specific number of
milliseconds with this so let's see what
that looks like and so it just slides up
and down or you can use the fade out and
fade in fade out and fade in and you can
do a combination of the milliseconds and
also I'm just gonna put normal here for
the amount of time so see you didn't
slide it all just to change the opacity
another thing you can do is the toggle a
toggle is just going to change the
display based on the current visibility
state so if it's currently hidden it
will show the content if it's currently
shown it will hide the content so we put
toggle and this I'm not gonna pass in
anything so if I toggle it this is gonna
be really quick it went off and then
came back on it came back on because of
the fade in so it toggle is just gonna
make it disappear if it's already
appeared but you can also pass in speeds
here so I'm gonna pass in some
millisecond so I'll put 700 milliseconds
let's see what happens now so it's going
to hide and then fade in hide so it's
kind of weird that it's going up and
then when you fade in it starts at full
height and then though pass the it goes
100% but I could also put toggle here
using toggle here is just like putting
hide or show but it just does the
opposite of whatever states currently in
you can also do
slide toggle or fade toggle so if it's
slid down it will slide up if it's lit
up will slide down or fade toggle if
it's disappeared it will reappear if it
is reappeared it will disappear okay now
I want to talk about doing something
after an animation completes so if we
hide this element and then we're gonna
do a fade in so I'm gonna fade in for a
thousand milliseconds so nothing fancy
here is just gonna fade in just like
that and now we're gonna do a method
chaining so if you method chaining you
can put in a lot of methods at the same
time so I'm gonna add a class blue now
I'm going to quickly go up into the CSS
here and for a class blue I'm going to
change the background to blue and you
will see it's gonna fade in and it's
going to add the class blue so let's see
what happens here and actually to make
this more apparent I'm gonna change the
amount of time to 2,000 milliseconds so
you can see even though the fade in
comes before the add class they
basically happen at the same time so
this starts to fade in and then adds the
class right away before the fade in is
even done if you want to defer an action
until after an animation has run to
completion you need to use an animation
callback function so you can put a
callback function as the second argument
passed any of the animation methods let
me give you an example
after the milliseconds I'm going to put
a comma and now I'm gonna put in the
callback function let's see okay so now
we have this selector as this and this
is just gonna apply to what we're doing
the animation on which is the h1 and now
we're gonna add the class blue so let's
see what happens now I'll run that so it
fades in and then the background turns
blue now one thing you can do is stop an
animation so what I'm gonna do here
I'm going to attach a click event to the
image the freako camp image and then in
the function we're gonna stop the
animations we select the image to act
and then on click we're gonna run this
function where we select the h1 tag and
do dot stop it's gonna stop the
animation happening on the image so I'm
gonna run this and while its fading in
I'm going to press the image I just
click the image and you can see it's
slightly faded right now and it never
add the class of blue so if I run this
again you can see the full animation
running again and I'm gonna click the
image and it stops in the animation
before it finishes it does not and it
never gets the callback function so it
never adds the class of blue the last
thing I'm gonna show in this video is
the delay method so if you use delay
it's gonna introduce a delay between
animations so let me show you an example
of that so look at the paragraph at the
bottom I know there's some other
animations happening but when I run
again this again it's going to hide the
paragraph for a half second and then
it's going to delay for a full seconds
and then it's going to show for a point
three seconds so those are the basics of
JavaScript effects you can also do a few
more custom effects with the dot anim
method well thanks for watching my name
is beau Carnes don't forget to subscribe
and remember use your code for good